welcome to the program those of you who
are watching will see I'm wearing my
John fetterman hoodie today uh John
fetterman did indeed win his Senate race
yesterday that is really good news and I
want to start with results from these
extraordinarily important 2022 midterms
I will not rehash all of the reasons why
these midterms are so important not the
least of which however it should be said
is trying to maintain a democracy in
which not just this year but in two
years in 2024 we can be confident that
the candidates who get the most votes
are accepted as the winners and assume
their offices without controversy and we
know that that almost didn't happen in
2020 expectations increasingly were for
an overwhelming red wave that would
devastate Democrats it didn't happen
it didn't happen we still don't know
it's still unclear big picture
who's going to end up controlling the
house uh Republicans have picked up
seats but as of right now we don't know
who will control the house
we don't know for sure who will control
the Senate but things are looking
increasingly okay there for Democrats
and some critical gubernatorial races
Maga can that its failing miserably and
this result is a disaster for
Republicans now I know that there are
people tweeting me saying David
Republicans will probably still take the
house and then the Senate's going to be
split what do you mean it's a disaster
for Republicans historically Republicans
should have done really well and based
on all of the polling that Republicans
themselves were pointing to they were
saying this is going to be overwhelming
it's going to be open and shut
Republicans easily take the house with a
nice margin Republicans take the Senate
Republicans win all of the critical
gubernatorial races none of that is
happening
none of that is happening
um Oz and mastriano lost
Tudor Dixon lost Herschel Walker
currently losing but probably heading
towards a runoff and we will see where
that goes Lauren bobert might lose
bobert an incumbent Maga Republican
Blake Masters down it will probably be
called today for his opponent Mark Kelly
Sarah Palin laughed away Kerry Lake we
don't yet know but she very well may
lose even though it increasingly was
being said oh Kerry Lake's gonna win and
if Republicans take the house it will be
by the smallest margin let's get right
into it starting with the Senate who
will control the Senate right now we
know
48.48 Republicans have so far not made
any pickups and Democrats have as of
right now made one pickup if we looked
at flipped seats that is indeed
Pennsylvania where John fetterman has
defeated television Dr Mehmet Oz with 94
percent of the vote in it is fetterman a
little over 50 Oz a little over 47 about
three points separating them that is a
really good result fetterman is a really
good candidate who suffered a stroke
some months ago struggled in a recent
debate
clearly not a cognitive issue if you've
seen in particular his speeches recently
if you see him right this is an auditory
processing issue and it seems that the
voters realize that now what's the
Counterpoint
quack TV Doctor Who has no business
being Senator almost won
right that you you can always find pros
and cons there if we go back to the
broader Senate map a critical race is
that in Georgia Raphael Warnock the
incumbent Democrat trying to beat off a
challenge from serial liar and
completely clueless barely able to speak
former football player Herschel Walker
there is What's called the 50 rule in
Georgia if neither candidate gets 50
percent there would be a runoff there
are three candidates and the Third Party
candidate Oliver has just over two
percent of the vote right now
Rafael Warnock is leading by half a
point which is 18 000 votes no matter
where this shakes out if it's Warnock by
half a point or Walker by half a point
it doesn't look as though either will
get to that 50 Mark meaning there will
be a runoff if that's the case we're all
going to Georgia and I don't know if I
will physically be going to Georgia I
may or we may try to figure out
digitally how to pour everything we can
Herschel Walker must not be allowed to
become a senator in the United States
it's horrifying other important races in
North Carolina it briefly looked like
Beasley might have a chance the Democrat
at defense at taking that seat from Ted
Bud ultimately it did go for Ted Bud it
was expected but there was a brief
glimmer of hope there in Ohio JD Vance
did defeat Tim Ryan that was expected
the polling was really pretty clear
there an extremely important race is
Arizona
it has not yet been called
it is starting to look like it will be I
want to be careful because news
continues to break Blake Masters may be
the worst person in the world
as an individual Walker is less
qualified but Blake Masters seems like a
genuinely worse person Mark Kelly the
incumbent right now leading by five
there is speculation it might be called
today only 69 percent of the vote is in
there a couple of other key races in the
state of Nevada Adam laxalt has taken
the lead against Cortez masto that's
disappointing and we are going to keep
an eye on that and in Wisconsin we still
don't know for sure but with 94 percent
of the vote in Ron Johnson the incumbent
is looking like he's going to be able to
Stave off a challenge from Mandela
Barnes a great guy who has been a guest
on this program six percent of the vote
remains to be counted and we can
maintain some amount of Hope there so in
the Senate right now completely
plausible that Democrats maintain
control we will know probably within a
couple of days looking now at
gubernatorial races again
not a disaster for Democrats with what
we know so far Democrats have made two
pickups in terms of Governors and
Republicans have made none important
races there of course Pennsylvania were
thankfully Josh Shapiro a great
candidate a genuinely great candidate
has easily defeated conspiracy theorist
Maga Trump riot
steal the election lunatic Doug
mastriano
this could decide the 2024 presidential
election the winner of this race which
is Josh Shapiro will decide who is the
Secretary of State in Pennsylvania and
that person will run the 2024 election
which could decide who is president of
the United States of critical importance
we're also looking very strongly at
Arizona
um Kerry Lake a complete cuckoo for Coco
Puffs conspiracy theorist who wanted to
secede who wants to end all abortion a
dangerous dangerous woman right now
she's down six tenths of a point
we have to wait we are hopeful
we are hopeful Carrie Lake will lose in
Georgia as expected Brian Kemp did
defeat Stacey Abrams that's too bad but
it was expected based on the polling in
Texas Beto O'Rourke lost badly to
incumbent Greg Abbott Beto O'Rourke's
political future is definitely in
question after yet another worse than
expected loss in Michigan fortunately
this is another loss for Maga Tudor
Dixon the Trump endorsed conspiracy
theorist lost by 10 to the incumbent
Democratic governor Gretchen Whitmer uh
Wyo a Wisconsin rather was briefly in
question but Evers defeated Michael's by
about three and a half points that's
really great news and we're still
waiting for results from Oregon
which if the Republican Drazen or drazan
I forget the pronunciation were to win
in Oregon it would be the first
Republican governor in decades right now
kotech the Democrat is ahead by one
only 76 of the vote has been counted and
lastly we have the House of
Representatives the House of
Representatives the most likely to go to
Republicans indeed Republicans have
currently made 10 pickups they need 17
more seats to take control it was
apparently a foregone conclusion it is
now not a foregone conclusion if they
win it will be a small margin one
interesting race hard to focus on a lot
of races here but if we do go to
Colorado and you go to the Third
District the Third District you will see
that Lauren bobert is losing by 1.2
Lauren bobert if she is defeated would
be the second big Maga cartoon to lose
this cycle Madison cawthorne losing his
primary after not even a full term
it's possible Lauren bobert will lose as
well 90 of the vote is in she's the
incumbent she's a Maga extremist and she
is currently down by 1.2 this all may
come down in terms of the Senate to
Georgia there is no Red Wave the Red
Wave is dead do not let anybody trick
you and I will even have clips of
Republicans admitting this momentarily
but the Red Wave is dead there may be a
ripple
should have been a great midterm for
Republicans it'll end up being sort of
okay end of critical importance
Democratic Governors one in Pennsylvania
Michigan and Wisconsin
those three races this year could
determine who the next president of the
United States is and we'll have time to
talk about that as well Fox News hosts
and guests flipping their Lids as the
Red Wave collapsed crumbled it was like
you know when you put cotton candy in
water and it just disappears that was
the the Red Wave disappearing last night
check out some of these clips starting
with
Fox News pundit Mark Thiessen saying
this is a disaster for the Republican
party just think about this uh we
welcome back martesan and hell for
juniors of the panel
um we talked a lot about debates and
when some candidates did debates and
some didn't do them had the October 25th
debate been September 30th would this
race have changed well I I think it
might have or maybe it wouldn't have I
mean I think there's a broader issue
here which is that so think about this
we have the worst inflation in four
decades the worst collapse in real wages
in 40 years the worst crime wave since
the 1990s the worst border crisis in U.S
history we have Joe Biden who is the
least popular president since Harry
Truman says now none of this stuff is
true and I'll prove it in a moment
presidential polling happened and there
wasn't a red wave that is a searing
indictment of the Republican Party All
right so a lot a lot a lot of admitting
there that this is a disaster Brian
Kilmeade with a similar perspective
repeating many of the same lies shifted
and right now zeldin's probably within
five points it might be out of reach for
him there's no big concession there you
see there's some unhappiness but I don't
know about you guys I'm shocked there
was a no Red Wave if you think about
inflation a 40-year high crying the
worst since the 1980s the unpopular
president with an agenda that's more
green oriented than people oriented yeah
they are telling you all lies okay yes
they are correctly pointing out the Red
Wave failed credit to them for pointing
that out but let's fact check this I
love it worst inflation in four decades
they say
reality it's the worst inflation since
1989 it's 33 years it did hit pieces of
four decades maybe we give them a pass
on that one but check out some of these
other ones worst collapse in real wages
in 40 years that would take us to 1982.
that is very clearly not true
median inflation adjusted that's what
they mean by real inflation adjusted
wages
that is not a chart that suggests now
wages are at their lowest point in 40
years in fact it is very much the
opposite very very much the opposite
we're at a peak not at the bottom they
are liars they said worse crime since
the 1990s or the 1980s even that's also
not true here's the crime rate since the
1990s and as you can see it has actually
declined over that period of time it is
declined even if you look specifically
as we will do now at murder homicide
those rates have also declined although
they have very recently ticked up a hair
but overall it is part of a downward
Trend worst border crisis in history
they say well I don't know how you
measure that is it the number of people
you catch or that you don't catch it is
true that arrests at the order are up
but that means we're catching people
that means they're not getting in here
how is that a crisis and importantly
nothing really has changed under Biden
since Donald Trump at the border and
then lastly they they said Biden least
popular president since Truman
that's not true Joe Biden right now is
about as popular as Trump was at this
point in his presidency about as popular
as Ronald Reagan was at this point in
his presidency within a point or two of
Barack Obama and Clinton's popularity at
this point in their presidencies and by
the way were it not for 9 11 which
buoyed George W Bush's approval rating
uh Biden would be doing better than
George W bush as well that the reason
Bush ended up with temporarily a higher
approval was 9 11. okay every claim is a
lie they are Furious maybe look at
reality
historically low unemployment
um stock market GDP you know all the
indicators we talk about and then maybe
they would be a little bit less shocked
Republicans in Arizona wasted no time
claiming fraud yesterday there is
absolutely nothing to this but they
wasted no time claiming fraud Charlie
Kirk who lives in Arizona and was very
involved with the Kerry Lake campaign in
Blake Masters tweeting out two-hour wait
minimum at most polling places in
Maricopa Democrats running elections
here knew this would happen traffic jam
by Design don't let them do 2020 again
wait in line and vote
it turns out actually that Democrats
don't run elections in Maricopa County
the Board of Supervisors is four
Republicans and one Democrat
same thing with the County Recorder 2020
was safe and secure in Arizona but they
were starting to catch up on this
Arizona stuff here's Brett Baier saying
it's a little suspicious over there we
kind of knew that this election was
going to happen
you know I mean right
for a while how about how about we fix
the machines I mean why is this
happening can we get our head around
there are going to be problems all over
the country some problems but
for it to happen here for it to happen
now in this way is kind of strange no
well what you have to remember is it's
not that it's happening it's that
Republicans decided we're going to say
that there's fraud in Arizona
really there were no Waits or very short
weights in most places residents are
allowed to vote at any polling place
they want not just the one nearest their
home and there's a very good NPR piece
Arizona's Maricopa County says it's
identified a solution for voting
equipment issues there was an issue with
a tabulator
um it was dealt with
it was not a huge deal but rest assured
if Kerry Lake loses she's losing right
now but we have to wait until all the
votes are counted if Carrie Lake loses
she will say it was fraud
let's take a quick break and be right
back with a very very busy news day
today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
I know it's almost too soon to even say
this but the 2024 election is on and you
will see in the next six days just how
quickly it ramps up we have a new coupon
code 24 starts now which you can use at
joinpakman.com I would love for you to
sign up on my website and become a
member there were some genuinely
concerning news items yesterday related
to the elections and one of them came
out of Ron desantis's Florida as well as
Missouri Washington Post reports Florida
Missouri tell justice department voting
monitors to stay outside of polling
places Federal monitors would need local
permission to observe activity inside
election sites the administration of
Governor Ron DeSantis has refused to
allow justice department election
monitors to go inside polling locations
in South Florida saying in a letter it
would be counterproductive and
potentially undermine confidence in the
election Monday the justice department
had announced it was send monitors to 64
jurisdictions Nationwide
up from 44 in 2020 to evaluate how are
elections being conducted amid a wave of
threats to workers working at elections
politicians and allegations of voter
intimidation Miami-Dade Broward and Palm
Beach counties were slated to receive
Justice Department Civil Rights division
monitors Florida Federal monitors were
sent to some Florida localities in 2020
but they stayed outside because of the
pandemic Brad McVay the chief counsel
for the Florida Department of State said
in a letter those monitors will not be
allowed inside polling places under
Florida law
McVay said the Florida Secretary of
State's office overseen by DeSantis
would instead send its own monitors
right
DeSantis is on the ballot it's totally
logical to send desantis's own monitors
to make sure everything is on the up and
up that makes sense right that makes a
lot of sense now there is a debate here
as to whether DeSantis has the authority
to stop the monitoring and
um what the Washington Post article says
is while the justice department is
permitted to place monitors inside
polling locations the department must
receive permission from local election
officials
the justice department has said it
followed standard procedure on Tuesday
has monitors outside polling locations
in Florida and Missouri where State
officials said they would not be
welcomed inside this is not some big
Smoking Gun it's just another example of
how the right is all about we need
monitors we need observers we need this
that the other thing we will train you
to become such an individual oh the doj
wants to send money oh no that would be
counterproductive to have them inside
I thought more monitoring is good and
it's just another little data point
about how their principles are worthless
monitoring elections is good
if it's their monitors if it's their
organizations but if it's the doj all of
a sudden we don't need that it would be
a obtrusive it would be
counterproductive not a surprise that as
soon as it's inconvenient they abandoned
their so-called principles
failed former president Donald Trump had
a complete and total meltdown over the
Maga disaster in the 2022 midterms
tantruming like a child over the last 24
hours Trump has gone cuckoo and as it
increasingly became clear there will be
no Red Wave there might be a ripple
we're still waiting
but there's not going to be a wave as it
becomes clear that Trump's likely
forthcoming presidential run
announcement next Tuesday at Mar-A-Lago
may not be met with open arms by
Republicans we'll get to that a little
bit later
Donald Trump pulling out all the stops
stops and making a complete and total
fool out of himself here is a real quote
from Trump about last night's results on
news Nation
if Republicans win
he should get all the credit
if Republicans lose he should get no
blame at all
that's not a joke that's actually what
Trump said you've endorsed more than 330
candidates this election cycle tonight
win or lose the results for Republicans
um how much of that will be because of
Donald Trump
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all okay but it'll
probably be just the opposite he he sang
it with a straight face guys
he's not joking it's just like with
covet where he said I don't take any
responsibility
he's not joking uh when they win I think
they're going to do very well I'll
probably be given very little credit
even though in many cases I told people
to run and they ran and they turned out
to be very good candidates you know
they've turned out to be very good
candidates but usually what would happen
is when they do well I won't be given
any credit and if they do badly they
will blame everything of me so I'm
prepared for anything but we'll defend
ourselves what a victim what a victim
now he said it again with a completely
straight face as Arizona started looking
shaky and people like Carrie Lake and
Blake Masters and Charlie Kirk started
panicking and saying we've we got to
start claiming that there is fraud here
Donald Trump took to truth social and
delivered a very very strange message
Trump looking disheveled and confused
and gaunt to some degree
and again suggesting that they there is
some conspiracy to prevent them from
voting in Arizona there was no such
conspiracy here's Trump delivering a
panicked message
to the great people of
County in particular don't leave your
line stay where you are they say that
the machines aren't working they say
that they're running out of paper in
different locations throughout different
states there's a lot of bad things going
on stay online do not leave I know you
don't want to be there as long as
they're going to try and force you they
want to delay you out of voting right
they want to delay you why I don't know
and you cannot let them delay you out of
voting so to the people of Arizona in
particular because that's the one that's
come up right now stay online don't
leave already a lot of people have left
and it's very very unfair what's going
on
Maricopa County don't leave stay there
all right uh again we already sorted out
the Arizona stuff at the top of the show
there was really no big deal going on
there issue with the tabulator they
dealt with it and no evidence that
anybody's votes were suppressed in any
way and then Donald Trump posting about
his endorsement record remember what
matters is his own endorsement record to
him impossible to pretend they all won
Trump posting that he was 174 and 9. a
great evening and the fake news media
together with their partner in crime the
Democrats are doing everything possible
to play it down amazing job by some
really fantastic candidates and remember
Trump mostly is endorsing incumbents
and people who are obviously going to
win but do not be confused
the Republican party is really
considering whether it's time to bail on
Trump because a lot of his big
endorsements lost mastriano that was a
critical race lost Oz lost Tudor Dixon
lost
Carrie Lake and Blake Masters may lose
we don't yet know it's a long list Lee
zeldin lost uh this was not a
particularly good night for Trump when
you look at endorsements for the
critical races that really matter uh not
a particularly good night Trump knows it
Republicans know it we'll get to that a
little bit later very briefly I do want
to have as an interlude here it was a
very weird day for Elon Musk on Election
Day musk shared a Nazi meme to Twitter
and then told his followers to vote for
Republicans not a particularly normal
day Ellie Quinlan huftaling writing a
good summary of this in The Daily Beast
um Elon Musk posting a how times have
changed meme to Twitter this got 43 000
retweets and 180 000 likes in a couple
hours it's a Nazi meme it uses a photo
of a German soldier with a cage of
carrier pigeons during the Nazi invasion
of France it had about 14 000 retweets
in the three hours after it was posted
um and so
that was sort of a weird thing to do and
then Elon Musk suggested on Twitter that
everybody vote Republican Elon Musk
saying to independent-minded voters
shared power curbs the worst excesses of
both parties therefore I recommend
voting for a republican Congress given
that the presidency is democratic this
is very very stupid and I will tell you
why
even if in the abstract you believe that
absolute power
corrupts people absolutely
you have to consider what we're talking
about even when controlling the White
House House and Senate Republicans still
have extraordinarily ex when when
Democrats control those three
Republicans have shown they have
extraordinary power to obstruct the
things Joe Biden wants to do uh most
things require 60 votes in the Senate uh
Democrats have not had a super majority
and as a result everything has been a
fight for Democrats the idea that oh
Democrats have had basically carte
blanche to do whatever they want is
untrue so the framing of this idea is
untrue furthermore
divided power isn't good
just for its own sake if the people that
would hold some of that power
have no business doing so people like
Herschel Walker
people like Mehmet Oz Governors like
Doug mastriano or Kerry Lake and so this
is the prototypical what I call
enlightened Centrist type post Elon Musk
likes to say I'm an independent I've
mostly voted for Democrats up until this
year now I suggest voting Republicans
because we want you know they're both
the same and we've got to divide power
and blah blah blah this is the
prototypical prototypical enlightened
Centrist type argument it is nonsense
and fortunately there was no red wave
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show when you
spend months predicting a massive
overwhelming Red Wave where you say
Republicans are going to win everything
and they're going to win everything
easily and then it doesn't happen you
have to start figuring out who do you
blame and the Republican party is
floating the idea of blaming Donald
Trump
increasingly over the last 12 or so
hours 12 to 16 hours since we started
getting results in in the midterms
Republicans have been slamming Trump for
the election disaster which will at best
be a red Ripple the Red Wave is gone
um the question now becomes does this in
any way impact Donald Trump's plans to
announce for 2024 there has been a
dramatic shift in the betting markets in
terms of who voters rather who betters
believe will be the eventual Republican
nominee let's take it step by step and
we actually go to
Fox News articles for this
Fox News article published early this
morning conservatives Point finger at
Trump after Republicans underwhelming
election results he's never been weaker
many conservatives say Tuesday's
election shows it's time to move on from
Trump
all the this is a quote from Michael
Brendan Doherty a senior writer at the
National Review
all the chatter on my conservative and
Republican channels is Rage at Trump
like I've never seen
the one guy he attacked before election
day was DeSantis the clear winner
meanwhile all his guys are
essing the bed
Real Clear Politics reporter Phil Wegman
says Republican Source tells me after
tonight with Trump candidates
underperforming and DeSantis winning by
double digits 2024 is a free-for-all
everybody in the water if you want to
take on Trump he's never been weaker
hmm anecdotal tweets one user Max nordow
Kerry Lake over Karen Robson Doug
mastriano over Lou Barletta Mehmet Oz
Over Dave McCormick Jr Majewski Trump's
big November 15 announcement should be
an endorsement of Ron DeSantis for 2024
we can do better the Reagan Battalion
time to move on from Trump
if DeSantis in Florida wildly
overperforms all the hand-picked and
trump-supported Republicans in other
swing districts particularly if they
lose well then gosh that is going to be
a fascinating new narrative that will be
commented upon by positively no one
another Fox News article Trump blasted
across media Spectrum over Republicans
midterms performance bigger loser
tonight remember we spoke last week with
Angelo carisone and Angelo Carrison
agreed with my perspective on Fox Trump
and Republicans 2024. they're not
abandoning Trump yet
but they are setting up an escape hatch
an eject button call it what you will
wherein they are starting to seed
interviews with voters saying I kind of
like DeSantis over Trump they are
starting to publish articles about
others are saying Trump's time may have
come and gone
uh let's look at a little bit of uh of
this article as the midterm results
rolled in and the Red Wave long hoped
for had not materialized many pundits
and journalists pointed their fingers at
Trump
former Obama Campaign strategist David
Pluff on MSNBC said I think you have to
say Donald Trump has now presided over
two disastrous midterms
given the history of presidents in power
Democrats controlling all of Washington
inflation this should have been a much
stronger night for Republicans a bunch
of reasons for that but at the top of
them is Donald Trump he's deeply
unpopular he supported a bunch of
horrible Senate candidates who may end
up coughing up the football here
msnbc's Chris Hayes said Republicans
ascribe to Trump a totemic power he does
not have he screwed his own power he's
unpopular he screwed you today screwed
you it's not the full story but it is
part of the story and the sooner you
dump him the better it is for the
Republican party and American democracy
ABC's Jonathan Carl said it was unclear
who would control Congress but
Trump is the goat what I can and not the
greatest of all time
quote what I can tell you is The Biggest
Loser tonight is Donald Trump
one on CNN conservative commentator
Scott Jennings offered another blunt
analysis
uh saying quote there's a potential
narrative out of this night that if
you're a Discerning Republican voter
trying to figure out the future
direction of the party we once again
learned Trump is not a national winner
for the Republicans but DeSantis may be
the next evolution of someone who can
marry what you like about Trump but
recover some people that went away from
the party during Trump we'll link to
these articles and you can read all the
quotes Okay we don't yet have all the
results but it's not looking
particularly good
I'm going to show you a stunning number
for months and months and months Trump
has either been leading the betting
markets for 2024 Republican nominee or
tied with Ron DeSantis months and months
and months and months this is not a poll
okay this is People BET who do you
believe will be the Republican nominee
over the last few hours
Ron DeSantis has built the biggest lead
in the betting markets that he has had
this election cycle when you ask people
to bet on the question who will win the
2024 Republican Presidential nomination
the leader is now Ron DeSantis the way
this works is these are betting
contracts so with the santis you have to
put up 41 cents to win a dollar if it's
the santis whereas with Trump you only
have to put up 33 cents to win a dollar
the idea being
the more you have to put up to win a
dollar the more likely an outcome it is
this is we have not seen these numbers
at any point
it is the weakest that Trump has been in
years and the next question is does this
change Trump's plan to announce his
candidacy on Tuesday
okay
um let's now talk about Donald Trump's
plan
that he has made clear is his plan to
announce his candidacy on Tuesday uh at
Mar-A-Lago Donald Trump talking about uh
initially that he might announce in Ohio
he then decided that that is not what he
is going to do and then in Ohio he
actually said we are going to make the
announcement on November 15th so let's
go through this step by step starting
with what Trump first teased in Florida
a few days ago about Ohio take a listen
I will probably have to do it again but
stay tuned
okay so then the crowd cheers for a
while then Trump says the following
[Applause]
that's pretty good thank you
stay tuned to tomorrow night in the
great state of Ohio stay tuned we have a
big we have a big rally there okay so
then people thought he's going to
announce tomorrow he's going to announce
tomorrow did not happen because tomorrow
which was Monday Donald Trump decided
the announcement will be next Tuesday
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida
okay
so as recently as yesterday Donald Trump
was appearing on TV and still saying
I'm gonna do it this is the latest
all right well we're talking about your
announce I do want to bring up something
a lot of people been talking about you
this is not sped up by the way this is
normal speed last year are huge rallies
that we've seen we've covered many of
them here on Newsmax but you you said
that you're going to do this at
Mar-A-Lago on November 15th why the
significance of announcing at Mar-A-Lago
well I actually would have preferred
doing it at a rally but I didn't want to
take away from JD I didn't want to take
away from anybody else that you know was
at the particular rally even Mark
Israeli was so great it was unbelievable
in Miami right and I would have
preferred it and then I said you know I
take away I also take away maybe from
the day which is today because you know
you're talking about a big announcement
so I just felt that maybe it was better
off doing it where it's by itself a
little bit and it's just a few days
actually one week exactly one week later
and a lot of people are going to be
there but I I really like the idea of
doing it at a rally because you know
when you have 40 50 000 people and you
make that kind of an announcement and
they're all saying do it do it they're
screaming last night do it but uh so
what I did last night is that I'm going
to do it we're going to make a really I
think statement that people are going to
be very happy about yeah so the question
now becomes do the results from last
night change this plan if you're Trump I
don't think they do because Trump is the
endless narcissist as we all know I
think you can't sit Trump down and say
listen sir as he always claims people
say to him
um you engaged you uh engaged you
endorsed Tudor Dixon she lost badly
you endorsed uh Dr Oz he lost you
endorsed Doug mastriano he lost you
endorsed Blake Masters in Kerry Lake TBD
TBD we don't know what's going on there
you endorsed Herschel Walker
as of this moment he's losing it will
probably go to a runoff and then who
goes what's going to happen who knows
what's going to happen
it's not great and sure you endorse like
a hundred incumbents and they won but
incumbents tend to win that's not really
a big deal maybe you should consider not
running I don't know that even if you
show Trump the numbers I just showed you
in the last segment and show Trump what
folks since the last segment I think Ron
DeSantis has potentially even gained a
little bit and you show Trump listen the
betting markets increasingly say it is
going to be Ron DeSantis not you if this
is a contested nomination
I don't even know that in that case
you necessarily can convince Trump not
to do it it is clear that what was
previously a silent feeling within some
of the Republican party that Trump is
bad for the party is becoming a more
publicly acknowledged feeling whether it
actually changes Trump's plans next week
I don't know if indeed the announcement
happens we will cover it live and make
sure folks this this is the start of an
insane two-year period at minimum please
make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel more than 3 million
people watch our clips and don't
subscribe we need everybody on board for
what's coming over the next two years
and the defense of the Democracy that we
must carry out make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube we're going to
take a quick break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right something super interesting is
starting to happen within the Republican
party there is a campaign that has
started a silent campaign or let's not
silent a quiet campaign to be Donald
Trump's running mate in 2024. now Donald
Trump hasn't even announced many of
Donald Trump's endorses did terribly in
the midterms and lost there are
increasingly Republicans who say Donald
Trump shouldn't even run and as we
recently saw the betting markets now
feel that it is more likely that Ron
DeSantis is the 2024 Republican nominee
than it is Trump but there are Trump
sycophants the Trump suck UPS the Trump
Brown nosers who are desperate to be
Donald Trump's running mate one such
individual is radical republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green has been floated
as a possibility for Donald Trump's
running mate in 2024 we know that Donald
Trump after his falling out with Mike
Pence will not be choosing Pence to run
with him in 24 if indeed he chooses to
be a candidate and there have also been
Rumblings of is it possible that Ron
DeSantis would run or be Trump's VP I
don't think that's likely is it possible
that Kerry Lake if she becomes Governor
would then try to become Trump's VP
Marjorie Taylor green doesn't like it
and Marjorie Taylor green is now framing
this as DeSantis and Lake
shouldn't abandon their states abandon
their states this is very interesting
Marge is angling to be Trump's VP
earlier we also talked and we said if
anyone steps into the uh political ring
and tries to challenge president Trump
as far as being the Republican nominee
for 2024 we feel like it's political
suicide this is his
party this is his race to run do you
want to share your thoughts on that
yesterday's results call that assessment
into question by the way absolutely I
I he's the one that we elected in 2016
we re-elected him in 2020 and we will
elect him in 2024. what we need in this
country Brian is we need strong
Republican Governors like Ron DeSantis
we need strong Republican Governors we
didn't carry like to win in Arizona we
need strong Republican Governors to
fight stay in for eight years and save
their states not to abandon their states
and try to run for president or any
other big position so I wonder why she
feels that way this is for everyone
anyone that's considering running uh for
president in 2024 against President
Trump please support president Trump
because we need him back in the White
House yeah and we need him to be the
nominee so that he picks me to be his
running mate only a trump supporter
would view other candidates engaging in
the Democratic process as an act of
betrayal think about how backwards that
is think about it
Marjorie Taylor green is saying
if you don't simply lay down
and let Trump have the nomination if he
wants it it's in some way a betrayal if
you're a governor and you say I'm gonna
go run for president you're abandoning
your state all of this stuff is
completely self-serving and by the way
Marjorie Taylor green wants to be VP
despite the fact that she has done
absolutely nothing for her constituents
as a representative for the state of
Georgia they need Trump confirmed as the
de facto candidate quickly because they
want to put political pressure on the
investigations that are taking place to
try to end them they have a lot of
different reasons why they want Trump to
very quickly announce and have everyone
else get out of the way if indeed Trump
follows through with announcing next
Tuesday that's part of the motivation
they want everybody to get out of the
way they want to use it to try to
suppress investigations but also they
want to move on to this PR campaign for
Who Will trump choose as his running
mate Marjorie Taylor green wants to be
that person all right a couple other
little things I want to check in on and
then we'll do just a brief election
update based on the things that have
happened while we've been filming today
our good friends over at the good liars
that's Jason and davram they spoke to a
woman recently who says that right now
Dr fauci is in jail in Guantanamo Bay
and it's not just Dr fauci it's Obama
and it's also Clinton Obama
I go back to the question we've been
trying to answer for a long time
when
is it a cult member with a cult belief
when is it an ignorant person who simply
misinformed if the and if they're shown
the truth they will revise their views
and when is it mental illness
I don't know the answer let's see if we
can figure it out here what do you think
about Anthony fauci
my God I can't even believe he made it
this far
no I just the guy's gone
he's he's in get more
so really who else is in gitmo besides
Anthony fauci you know you got Hollywood
there you've got politicians you've got
Elites the clintons are there the Obamas
are there you know um it goes on and on
I don't want to be the one to sit here
and and misquote somebody or say
something but you don't want to say
anything irresponsible exactly right
like fauci Clinton and Obama are
currently at Guantanamo Bay
what do we do with this what do we do is
this we need better education
is this we need antipsychotic medication
like what is it that needs to be done
the most actionable takeaway at every
election should be she probably voted
yesterday I guess I mean sometimes these
people are super involved in this
superficial way
but then they don't actually vote but
let's let's assume she voted yesterday
we need to be voting to counteract the
vote of someone who thinks Dr fauci is
in prison right someone emailed me and I
don't know whether some of you think
there's something to this
someone wrote to me and said you know
David there's a reason why it's mostly
like baby boomer types who we see
repeating this crazy conspiracy stuff
that they get from Facebook and
elsewhere this is this is the view of
one of our viewers and what they said is
Baby Boomers simply didn't grow up with
the internet and social media people my
age didn't grow up with it but it sort
of cropped up when we were
10 12 14 and then people like my little
sister's age quite literally grew up
with it and what this person said is
a lot of folks just don't understand
how to discern fake news and
conspiracies
an actual
reliable information they don't know how
to discern reliable and unreliable
internet sources a fake News website is
designed just like New York times.com
and they quite literally can't tell the
difference
I don't know like is that is that ageist
is there something to the age thing
I mean my mom's never calling me and
falling for this stuff so I I don't know
that that's really what it's about but
it was an interesting idea
um just so everybody knows Dr fauci's
not at Guantanamo Bay
Barack Obama's also not there
and neither Bill nor Hillary or even
Chelsea Clinton are being held at
Guantanamo Bay one other but speaking of
psychosis by the way just one other
thing so many of you wrote to me and and
told me David something seems to have
happened here with Mike Lindell also
known as as Mike pillow
um in related to the election because
he's been doing some really really
strange TV appearances where he seems
truly to have lost it he claims he has
all sorts of people who are here or
there or I don't even know where
um yeah it is weird here is a clip in
which my my pillow Mike Lindell from his
airplane says he is somehow monitoring
every race for fraud people we're gonna
be watching every race we're gonna have
the real-time crime deaths going at
Frank speech.com Is that real like what
could they possibly be watching
everybody you can watch me there
tomorrow night um
I want all the bad guys out there to
know through the Edison report we are
watching and we also have another way to
watch what's going on with the computers
in the machine so I'm putting them all
on notice Steve they're all on notice so
that we are by the way you can turn in
at the
crime.franksbeach.com right if you
receive any irregularities you can
report it to pillow see anything turn it
in there yep
um and people say to me David is that
funny is that sad is it dangerous what
what exactly is that
um Mike pillow appeared
who the hell knows where it's so
difficult to even understand where these
appearances are happening this is
something called Victory I don't even
know what this is here he says you know
he's catching people red-handed this was
as the election results were coming in
last night or I want to bring in Mike
Lindell uh Mike you got some interesting
results you wanted to share go ahead
yeah well first of all when you guys
were talking before I was listening to
you who attacked our country and what is
this all about right it's the CCP the
unit party the Deep State the globalists
and now the Democrat Party joining with
all of them globalist
um here's what we have in our real-time
crime desk if you have a Graphic to put
up I'm going to show you just one of
them and this is from the Democrat so
we're watching these races Vance was one
did you I don't even know what that was
I mean it did that graphic he put up
meant nothing says chance was one I
believe they early on they were taking
it uh taking Advanced and I think they
just didn't put in the injection because
he totally overran the algorithm
injection we're watching these races and
it's like real-time crime I caught a
crime Spike and then you get these crime
spikes and but everybody
so listen is that psychosis I have no
idea not qualified to diagnose it it
certainly would be funny if it weren't
sad and more importantly it's extremely
dangerous because he has followers and
in all seriousness I don't understand
how his family can't get him some help
and get him out of this endless loop it
has been years now and pillow has said
I I I miss my time with my family
because I'm flying around doing all this
stuff I'm pouring I think he told me
during our interview 30 something
million into this stuff between lawyers
and Tech and who knows what the hell
else at some point you would think his
family could get him some help but it
does not seem to be happening we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad producer Pat will
join me we are going to zoom out and do
five big picture takeaways from the exit
polls the exit polls yesterday were
really interesting insofar as they asked
people about what do you think about the
direction of the country how did people
vote depending on that
who do you think won the 2020 election
how did people vote depending on that
you can probably guess we're going to
look at takeaways from the exit polls
secondly there is now increasingly the
claim being made Ron DeSantis is the new
Republican party leader Trump didn't
really endorse DeSantis he sort of
begrudgingly did on Monday
and DeSantis very much overperformed and
was re-elected governor meanwhile many
of the people Trump picked lost
so we're going to talk about that and
then we are also going to talk about
where abortion was on the ballot
yesterday it mostly saw voter support
and that is not shocking if you
understand the polling data but
interesting to see in a broader context
all of those stories and much more on
today's bonus show folks this is the
start this is the start of what will be
an insane two years in American politics
which hopefully doesn't end with the end
of democracy okay
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get the
bonus show you'll get commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
you'll be invited to our next member
only Town Hall you can use the brand new
coupon code 24 starts now that's 2-4
starts now no spaces all lower case or
caps doesn't matter 24 starts now also
make sure you're subscribed to our audio
podcast it's on every podcasting
platform whatever you use it's there
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
we are getting started for what is going
to be a major undertaking over the next
few years I'll see you on the bonus
foreign